It's important for us to take a
synopsis on the book itself. How did he
structure this book? Who did he gear it
towards? And what is this book comprised
of?
This book as it is titled
meaning the gardens of
the righteous.
The gardens here meaning the verbial
guardians in this world and the literal
guardians in the hereafter.
And it's a compilation of
predominantly
the most
relevant
words and times of the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii wasallam when we look at the
original books of hadith. So when we
mean the original books, we're talking
about the references. The books which
all other books that come after and
quote narrations will use as a reference
for their narrations.
We look at a book like
Muslim. We look at a book that comes
even before that Ahmed. These books
are written with a very particular
with a very particular
set of
conditions
in order that this book will will list
certain narrations gathered by this in
this way set up in a very particular way
in order to articulate
and add to a particular subject whether
it's in the area of f or whether it's in
the area of chains of narration or
whether it's in the area of
but these books are extensive they're
very complex
you have to study a lot and have become
very familiar with the author his time
the particular field that the author
is compiling his book for in order to
properly understand what the author
intends with the way that he has
structured his book. Sah Bkari is a book
that yes it is the ultimate resource and
the first of resources with regards to
the prophet Sam's
in Islam after which is Muslim. However,
these books are very complex and they
are not for the average person to just
crack open and start reading at any
point or at any place. And so the
scholars of Islam
the later scholars of Islam after the
fifth and sixth century, after the
seventh century, all the way until today
have always sought to compile narrations
of the prophet sallall.aii Wasam
and make these narrations accessible and
understandable
to anyone who reads their book. Whatever
their level of knowledge is, whatever
their whatever their level is with
regards to introduction to the
subject or the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam's words trying to make
it as easy as possible for anyone to be
able to pick the book up and read it and
understand exactly what the author
intended by it.
And so the scholars worked very
diligently to do things summarize
summarize
summarize or take select narrations even
from Ahmed and many many many books have
been written in this field with this
goal in mind. writing a book that is
accessible, making these narrations
accessible to every person, every Muslim
who picks up the book, regardless of his
level of knowledge, to be able to
understand for the most part without a
teacher. This is the idea behind it. And
so there have been many attempts, some
of them were , you know, hit the mark,
some of them missed the mark. They were
either too complex or too simple. Right?
However, the book of
did this in one of the most perfect ways
and it is compiled of a a little bit
short just just shy of 2,000 narrations.
Just shy of 2,000 narrations. And that's
actually a lot of narrations, right?
And
Muslim without repetition all together
collectively
without repetition is a little bit less
than 3,000 narrations. Some scholars
mention it to be a little bit more or a
little bit less. The point is is that
2,000 narrations,
these narrations are what you will find
to be the most common place narration
amongst the Muslims, the most
the most commonly cited the most
well-known narrations of the prophet Sam
where did these narrations come from
about 85%
of these narrations are from Bkari
Muslim and mainly Muslim why because
has a very special relationship with
Muslim and so you'll find that the
majority of the narrations that he cites
are fromahk and so they're agreed upon
then
he quotes a lot from
also rarely he quotes from
even more rarely he quot
and extremely scarcely he will quote
other books such as
or books
I'm getting to it. Let me finish
or he's given to or from books like
this is very rare extremely rare that
you'll find a narration from
or a narration from
or a narration from Ahmed. These are
extremely rare.
However, the majority of narrations are
from these three books
and activity. These are where the
majority of the narrations of come from.
One of the important things about
is that there is not a narration
mentioned
in
that the scholars of Islam have agreed
upon as being weak that doesn't exist.
So are there weak narrations in it's
debatable. However, there's not a
narration in
where all the scholars agree this is a
weak narration. He didn't quote any
narrations that.
Another point is there are no fabricated
narrations.
Also there are no extremely weak
So if you look at narrations they're on
different levels, right? There's that
which is most
authentic and then there is that which
is most rejected right that which we are
absolutely positive the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said and then
that which we are absolutely positive he
did not say and between those two points
there is a multitude of levels
multitude of levels with respect to the
authenticity of narrations.
Now he mentions most of his narrations
from Bkari Muslim and those are
authentic narrations which the Muslims
after the scholars of Islam have agreed
upon accepting the narrations of Muslim.
These are narrations that are above
reproach. However, however, there are
other narrations
which the scholars differ on. Some of
them may say this narration is
acceptable whilst others may say
this narration is too weak to be
acceptable. Therefore, we will consider
this narration to not meet the minimum
threshold of acceptability.
that gray area where the scholars
differ. Some narrations might be in from
there. But a narration that is agreed
upon to be rejected, no doesn't exist.
A narration that is agreed upon to be
fabricated or extremely weak, it doesn't
exist.
Alhamdulillah. Any narration that he
mentions that maybe perhaps other
scholars will quote as being weak, they
are narrations which are differed upon.
And as we mentioned before,
one of his specialties is the science of
hadith. And what that means is that if
says an narration is authentic, it is
acceptable to make of his opinion. If
you're unable to search and understand
the science of hadith enough to make
your own opinion and choose, if you hear
authenticated this narration, that's
enough. That's enough for you to accept
the narration.
And so he is a in this field of the
science of hadith. This is very very
important for us because again just like
you know the the scholars they have a a
saying and we'll end with this
they have a saying that
you know when you're if you look at kids
or people that
they come across a tree that has a lot
lot of fruits on it.
When they can't climb the tree to the
top to get these fruits down, they'll
take stones and start to pelt the stones
at these fruits to try to knock them
down. I'm sure most of us grew up in
that kind of environment, right? And so
the scholars say only the trees with the
most fruits hanging on them are the ones
that get pelted with the most stones,
right? Half of the Noah is who has a lot
of fruits in his life. His life and his
works were very fruitful, extremely
influential
to the point that if I were to try or if
a scholar were to try to completely
avoid the Noah in all research, in all
matters, it would be almost impossible.
He has been so influential
and his work so intrusive into all
fields of Islamic sciences or most
fields. And so any person who rises to
this kind of prominence, you're going to
find that he'll have a lot of haters, a
lot of enemies, a lot of people that
will slander him. Why? Because they're
trying to ride his coattails. any kids
that come out today on the internet or
and they make a YouTube channel and
their YouTube channel is all about how
alafi is a terrible person. We shouldn't
accept anything from him. And yes, those
channels exist unfortunately.
Why? This man died 800 years ago. Why
why is this a relevant topic for Muslims
today? Because if you're unable to
become
to to rise to prominence, usually not
always, but if you're unable to rise to
prominence in an orthodox way, a
shocking unorthodox way will usually do
it right. And so if you mention Noah, it
will ruffle feathers very quickly and it
will be very controversial and then your
name will start to be mentioned
alongside of his. This is the idea. So
is considered to be an authority in the
science of hadith. There are some that
disagree with him. Sure. However,
disagreement
amongst the scholars is something that
comes with knowledge and comes without
ulterior motives. And so when we look
at
we can safely say that narrations that
are looked at as being weak. They are a
difference of opinion and we will
mention some examples of that. There's
about 74 or 73 narrations in
that have been mentioned that. When
I reach any of those narrations, I'll
mention them to you and discuss the
correct opinion with regards to those
narrations. And none of those narrations
alhamdulillah are rejected in meaning
the meaning of these narrations are
accepted
even if the chain of narration itself
might be weak. So we will begin with
starting tomorrow inshallah and as we
mentioned before these are very these
are to be very concise statements
after starting tomorrow inshallah
just about five or seven minutes or
eight minutes to read a narration
translated and if there's any
misunderstanding
or anything that needs to be explained
but alhamdulillah most of them are
pretty self-explanatory
we ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
teach us of that which will benefit us
to benefit us from that which he teaches
us.
[Arabic recitation]